restemos 11 y 12 dieciseisavos menos
cinco y ocho dieciseisavos bueno a mí lo
primero que me gusta hacer es dividir
estos números mixtos en un número entero
más una fracción así es que lo primero
que yo haría sería escribir 11 más
doce dieciseisavos menos y lo voy a
poner entre paréntesis porque este menos
está afectando a todo este número mixto
y yo quiero dividir este número mixto en
un entero y una fracción entonces aquí
dentro del paréntesis va cinco enteros
más ocho dieciseisavos ok entonces este
signo de menos está afectando a estos
cinco enteros pero también está
afectando a esta fracción a estos ocho
dieciseisavos ok entonces lo que tenemos
son nuestros 11 enteros más 12
dieciseisavos
menos 5 enteros nuestros 5 enteros y
después menos
ocho dieciseisavos ok entonces ya que
quitamos los paréntesis lo que yo hago
es sumar primero los enteros y después
las fracciones así es que vamos a sumar
primero 11 enteros menos 5 enteros ok
entonces tenemos 11 menos 5 y después
sumamos las fracciones o sea vamos a
sumar 2 de dieciseisavos más 12
dieciseisavos menos ocho dieciseisavos
menos ocho dieciseisavos
11 5 son 6 enteros y para hacer esta
resta de fracciones como tenemos el
denominador común los dos denominadores
son iguales a 16 lo único que tenemos
que hacer es restar los numeradores así
es que nos va a quedar como denominador
el mismo denominador 16 y luego 12 menos
84 o sea 6 más 4 dieciseisavos y esta
suma de un número entero más una
fracción es igual al número mixto 6
enteros y 4 dieciseisavos 6 enteros y 4
dieciseisavos
esta es la resta de 11 enteros y 12
dieciseisavos menos 5 enteros y 8
dieciseisavos sin embargo este número se
puede simplificar más o sea esta
cantidad es la correcta pero esta
fracción se puede simplificar más porque
el 4 divide tanto al 4 como el 16 y
siempre hay que dejar el número lo más
simplificado que podamos
entonces tenemos que dividir arriba y
abajo entre 4
ok y como estamos dividiendo arriba y
abajo entre la misma cantidad
la fracción va a ser equivalente a ésta
entonces lo que tenemos es que seis y
cuatro dieciseisavos es exactamente
igual a seis enteros y cuatro entre 41
y 16 entre 44 o sea 6 enteros y un
cuarto esta es la respuesta correcta